[موسيقى]
الصبيئه على غرار العديد من مكونات
المجتمع العراقي تواجه منذ وضع الدستور
العراقي مشكلات نجمه تتعلق بالتشريعات
والقوانين وبالرغم من وجود دائره الاحوال
المدنيه الصبيئيه لكن لدور اساسيه لها ما
عدا تدخلها في مسائل الزواج او الطلاق
احنا يعني نتمنى ان
تنتبه
الجهات التشريعيه بالحقيقه
نتمنى ان يكون عندنا راي عام حتى ناثر على
الجهات التشريعيه
لتعديل هاي القواني بما يخدم بقاء طائفه
السابقه
احنا عندنا
القاتل حرام
ذبح حتى يعني ذبح الطير عندنا لازم نخليه
لك شاهد يوقف يقول انا اشهد انه انت ذبحت
هذا الطير لاجل انساك وانت جاي مو لان انت
بطران مو لان انت قاتل لذلك احنا ما
نستطيع ان نحمل السلاح بوجه حتى القاتل
مثل هكذا طائفه مسالمه
وهي جذور الارض الرافدين بالحقيقه
جذور الارض الرافدين خساره مثل هذه
الطائفه من العراق هي خساره كبيره خساره
مو احنا كطائفه لا خساره للعراق
هو العراق نصف خلق
هو من مكونات
هو
غير متجانس
المكونات لكن نفس الموروث الثقافي لكن نفس
المشاعر نمتلك جميعا لكن نفس الروح
العراقيه نمتلك جميعا نفس الروح السوق ام
مريم
هاجروا السابق ناعم
على الوضع في الدول
نحن نسال الحفاظ على ما تبقى منهم فهم
يحتاجون الى تشريعات هذه
القانون التنوع الدينيه والثقافي قانون
المهم قانون حمايه التقليات والاهم من ذلك
وقانون همم البطاقه الوطنيه همم ماده 26
همم نحن نسعى ونعمله مع العديد منظمات
المجتمع المدني ومع الاختبارات كذلك نواب
الخليات من اجل همم
مسوده
لتشري بس نوافقه قريب ان شاء الله راح
تنتهي هذه المسوده همم يعني التاجر
المكونات الى عديد من التشريعات قوانين
وكذلك تحتاج الى توفير عنصر الاموي
والامان وكذلك التمثيل المهم في رئاسه
الحكومه في رئاسه الجمهوريه من اجل ان
يشعر ابناء المكونات انهم جزء اساسي
وحقيقي في هذا البلد